[Applause]
hey easy born in New York kicks earth
game and roll rotation by don't get it
twisted Lucy well chose to show today
some chick let's see if we onto it for
two months I probably have like
beautiful rotation changes in there Tom
out of these Perry kicks the ones don't
think there's lasted longest is these d
squared so and he's been through a lot
but I never give what they been through
I love them
it cost me like sixteen hundred bucks
there's dead the d squared story here in
Soho my first time going shopping in
Soho so it was my birthday I'm glad to
buy me something I bought me some these
squares and they got the fur on the side
they got the fur on the inside they got
the multiple different laces they got
the strap it's just a lot going on on
his shoes but not eleven they been
through a lot they've been all over the
world with me and I love him with all my
heart then you come up on some new bike
these are relatively new these Gucci
these buy like I said we just got these
from Nike for The Frisky shout out to
[Music]
what's crazy about these is uh the
inside you see all this
so like this this part of the shoe will
never be seen yo like this does not come
off the soles
got got art on it it says our solar
system look at the planets Mercury Venus
clove hitch this is dope to put art on
the inner sole reclaim your soul ladies
and gentlemen
so yeah shout out to Nike to these do
you like some some everyday everything
does you know I never go wrong with the
little vapor man but I mean I got
another little pair that I use for my
workout shoe that I never look pair I
use in my life day to day these are just
comfortable these are the og bo
Jackson's Bono's Karachi's and these are
my workout shoes
leave home without your workout shoes
it's great to go get some push-ups or
exercise or whatever you wanna do blow
off some steam these are actually
intended to be workout shoes these are
Alexander Wang's I workout she
definitely said at the store but I'm
there fighting for that perfect they
have funny I was gonna win so you know
training this that's cool is in the wind
and these collab with anybody this is
like workout around like any one of
these things at you drop it but we are
getting them and they do it we just got
these from under these AC G's for Nike
these are super color I put these on
yesterday after I got off stage and
wearing these and like I usually a walk
around with my boots I was like I'm not
wearing our boots after the show and
eating my foot it's there right in these
jumps they snug a super comfortable man
and he's definitely Suvarna shoes I got
these I got so I got these in two
different colors pieces my life
alternatives to like getting off stage
and I walk around super soft super clean
easy kappa kappa / i just like this you
know sound like something bright and
slice and walking around i don't know if
y'all know the company called chinatown
market everybody got like these kind of
models of swat means little icing like
spot means riding side so when you put
them on and especially you get punished
things and lights are reflecting off of
you
exactly it's a whole different vibe
people came in and see my feet in the
picture it's just like shining is
nothing in the picture i put it for that
aspect I usually start off with what
shoes I'm gonna perform in I just like
the craziest shoes sometimes sometimes I
pick like like these are amazing these
remind me of some shoes that I was such
a rollin I like some snow boot kind of
joint I usually have these snow boots
that I've been rocking for like two or
three tours they actually motorcycle
riding boots but who would think there's
no booze just because I saw giriboy
stuff every time my heart don't stays
burning the fans will go crazy like you
know saying
so that's that's the reaction that you
want to get from the people so whatever
it takes I like wearing shoes that makes
people you know I'm saying that gives
kids reaction out of people you say what
you want about Kanye West but he makes
great these like kind of go with
everything so and like you to a lot you
you go to all types of terrain you know
Sam I ran in here snowing here dusty
here so you want something that you can
just slip in a night and get to where
you're going with without damaging your
other shoes so these are wear a lot
because these take the beating okay
Kanye West can handle the beating these
were 69 and I bought as much diversity
the more like and I will never do it I
will never spend more $2,000 on fish
these are like 600 this is the most
these these dsquared boots not I think
it retails like fourteen would take the
end of me almost in 1611 it was the most
expensive shoe however I ever ever ever
got and they only lucky no more and I'll
give they are super durable and they are
my favorite shoes like I don't care what
they go through with it in a book like
laces have you ever said it's happened
to him but they are my favorite one for
me it was these these diesease was like
six hundred understand but like I
haven't seen nobody with a parody so I'm
like to me it's not really about how
much they cost
it's just about how rare they are that's
all I really care about it's really like
am I gonna see anybody else in this if
not those are the that's exactly what I
want I don't care about name brands you
know that stuff and I remember first was
you gonna put it up on a Nike office and
it was all the way see first image it we
always like to I was on this rainbow
together and I first time ever doing
anything free we all just walk down with
so many boxes the white one carry
through boxes anything you don't like in
the boxes don't get in your suitcase if
I if I was a balls at home person here
this is Road
well rotation ease that a whole point is
yeah straight up straight up
[Music]